as expected then another uh interest
rate Riser the 10th in a row bear in
mind this is what's been going on all
around the world the U.S federal reserve
last night raised its main policy rate
fed funds albeit by a quarter point the
European Central Bank in around three
quarters of an hour's time is expected
to confirm that it's raising its main
policy rate by half of one percent as
well so uh that is uh really what is
expected here as I say what we want to
do is uh find out the composition of the
uh votes I'll see if I can get any uh
information on that while we uh while we
go through it nothing on the screen's us
yet but really no surprise there
um in terms of I'm trying to look at it
and there's still no word on the
composition yet maybe uh someone can
find that out uh obviously the bank of
England was facing something of a of a
of a dilemma here because all of the
background mood music to the economy is
not great uh if you look for example at
manufacturing activity with the latest
purchasing managers index survey data or
pointing to a Slowdown there in
manufacturing and there's a lot of
talking of recession in the air and that
is something that the bank will be
really really cognizant of they don't
want to uh overdo it uh in terms of
tightening monetary policy in case they
make a possible recession worse remember
of course that the UK did not go into
recession at the end of last year as had
been widely expected including by the
bank of England itself that was uh their
their Central forecast as well
um I'm just trying to see if we we do
have any yeah and I'm just reading here
that um the bank of England's nine
interest rate Setters voted seven to two
to increase the bank rate to four
percent I don't have details of what the
other two voted for at present but no
doubt you will find that information
that will be that is very uh interesting
and I mean that confirms basically that
uh the the doves remain doves I suspect
it will be the same to uh individuals
who voted uh in favor of maintaining
interest rates where they were last time
around that search Richard dingra and uh
Savannah 10 Ray Rome Just leading the
MPC statement now Anna the key point
they make is that Global Consumer Price
inflation remains higher though it's
likely to have peaked across many
advanced economies including in the UK
so that's a a warning that uh that will
notice from the bank that they do expect
rates to come down uh they're talking
about wholesale gas prices here but
here's the key point I think here anna
UK domestic inflationary pressures have
been firmer than expected both private
sector regular pay growth and services
PMI inflation have been notably higher
than forecast in the November monetary
policy report the labor market remains
tight by historical standards although
it started to loosen and some survey
indicators of wage growth have eased so
the bank making the point there really
it's these high levels of uh of wage
inflation that they're starting to see
creeping through which means that they
had very little choice to but to to
raise interest rates uh right now and
again I'm looking at the concluding
remarks here around the policy statement
it's all about the fact that
inflationary pressures here in the UK
have been firmer than expected and the
MPC cognizant of the fact that CPI the
headline rate of inflation currently
more than five times higher than the
bank's Target rate here's the
composition then uh it was indeed Swati
dingra and silvano tenrero they prefer
to maintain interest rates back rate at
three and a half percent so really no
change in the balance between the uh the
doves and the Hawks there on the
monetary policy committee and here's the
forward-looking bit that I think the
market will be most interested in uh the
line here looking further ahead the MPC
would adjust bank rate as necessary to
return inflation to the two percent
Target sustainably in the medium term
and uh again another kicker here uh the
extent to which domestic inflation
repressures ease will depend on the
evolution of the economy including the
impact of the significant increases in
Bank rates so far there were
considerable uncertainties around the
Outlook the MPC will continue to monitor
closely indications of persistent
inflationary pressures including the
tightness of labor market conditions and
the behavior of wage growth and services
inflation and here's the key line I
think that everyone's going to hang
their hats on today if there were to be
evidence of more persistent pressures
then further tightening in monetary
policy would be required so interest
rates blank rate at four percent right
now as I said just before we got that
decision the markets are pricing in
right now uh bank rate to Peak at around
4.8 percent well the monetary policy
committee there in those uh in those
minutes making very very clear that
there are likely to be further interest
rate Rises uh to come we are not at uh
what Market participants yet refer to as
the terminal rate there will be further
interest rate Rises to come if these
sort of levels of inflation remain
persistent now bear in mind that
inflation expectations uh are the the
expectations around inflation is that it
will Peak around mid-year and then start
to come or it's it's already picked in
October last year but we expect it to
start to tail off quite rapidly come the
middle of the year as you uh reach
annualized uh effects uh of the of the
commodity price inflation uh increases
that we saw last year